m'entendez oui on vous entend on vous
entend très bien Jérôme Durin président
cette commission d'enquête accompagné
d'Étienne BLANC rapporteur qui est à mes
côté et puis de sénatrices et de
sénateur qui sont sal m d'ici et qui
vous poseront des question tout à
l'heure je vais commencer par vous
remercier de votre présence d'avoir
répondu à notre demande d'audition et
puis par un une prestation de serment
qui est formelle
euh et qui est requise par notre
commission d'enquête puisque je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
une commission d'enquête seraitible des
peines prévu aux articles 434- 13 434-1
et 434-15 du code pénal et donc je vais
vous inviter chacune et chacun d'entre
vous successivement à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
à lever la main droite et à dire
simplement je le
jure pour le président du tribunal Mar
je le jure pour le procureur je le jure
mal première vice-présidente au pénal je
le
jure Alexandre Magri substitut du
procureur de la République je
jure écoutez je vous remercie de d'avoir
satisfait cette obligation et puis ce
que je vous propose c'est comment vous a
transmis un questionnaire qui traduit
nos principales préoccupations et les
informations qu'on souhaite obtenir à
l'ISS de cette audition c'est de vous
laisser peut-être dérouler un propos
liiminaire et ensuite on vous posera des
questions ça vous convient je vous
laisse vous organiser pour savoir qui
qui commence écoutez c'est parfait donc
le procureur de la République et
moi-même échanger avec nos collègues
donc ça sera une des réponses en à deux
voix la voix du parquet et la voix du
siège à Cayenne donc Monsieur le
Procureur de la République qui sera
accompagné de la meilleure des manières
par Monsieur rousle Magri prendra à
chaque fois le le la parole en premier
pour vous apporter des éléments espérons
que cela puisse vous correspondre vos
attentes et côté siège donc Madame
Sigala et moi-même compléteront le les
propos de nos collègues du parquet qui
sont en première ligne nous faisons un
travail complémentaire donc on vous
propose de faire de la façon suivante
donc monsieur Leclerc qui prend la
parole complété de Monsieur Rous Magri
et ensuite ma côté siège madame Sigala
et
moi très bien
parfait bonjour Est-ce que vous
m'entendez parfaitement parfaitement
très bien alors en propos liminire je
souhaitais d'abord vous apporter TR
trois observations avant de de dérouler
les les questions que vous m'avez vous
nous avez transmises la première c'est
une observation
géographique la Guyane c'est tout
simplement une porte ouverte vers
l'Amérique du Sud une porte ouverte sur
ses mots et sur ses nombreux mots
puisque en plus du narcotrafic qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui euh nous avons un
niveau de de
criminalité de violence et d'usage des
armes qui est totalement inconnu en
Europe c'est très clair et c'est dans
cet environnement que s'inscrit les
trafics de stufféfiant parmi donc tous
ces toutes ces problématiques auxquelles
on est confronté au quotidien l'action
qui est conduite 2uxè observation elle
elle sort pas de d'une d'une invention h
elle s'inscrit et elle est l'application
la circulaire de politique territoriale
du 29 septembre 2022 nous sommes une des
seules juridictions en France à avoir
une circulaire de politique pénale
territoriale dans laquelle bien entendu
vient s'inscrire la lutte contre contre
les
stupéfiants cette lutte elle est
articulée autour d'une d'une politique
d'optimisation transverse de tous les
outils juridiques dont dispose
l'ensemble des partenaires pour essayer
de porter atteinte sur ce continent donc
et sur ces spécificité à ce qui à mon
sens a le plus de valeur au-delà du
produit c'est l'acte logistique de
projection de des stupéfiants depuis
l'Amérique du Sud vers le vers l'Europe
c'est là que le produit va obtenir et va
acquérir sa vraie valeur
ajoutée
le les deux points de d'exportation euh
sont essentiellement l'aéroport et le
port et donc c'est face à cette
dimension logistique que se concentrre
tous nos tous nos efforts voilà un peu
les les les éléments de de de contexte
que je voulais vous livrer euh pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée en terme de
violence je pense que la le le général
vous a peut-être évoqué la question mais
euh plus d'un tiers de l'ensemble des
volamin armé constatés par la
Gendarmerie nationale ont lieu en Guyane
ça vous donne une idée du niveau
d'intensité auquel on est confronté avec
la présence d'organisations criminelles
sud-américaines qu'on appelle les les
les factions brésiliennes qui sont une
vraie problématique et une vraie menace
non seulement pour la sécurité de la
Guyane mais aussi pour la métropole
puisque ces gens-là ont dév léité
d'exporter leur mécanismes mafieux donc
en France voilà un peu le le contexte
euh vous le savez mais on appelle mulle
et c'est le la terminologie que je vous
propose de retenir donc des individeurs
qui sont porteurs incorporés de d'ovule
de cocaïne pour des quantités qui
varient autour d'un kg entre 1 kg et et
1,5 et c'est donc cette sous cette dénom
sur ce mode opératoire qu'on qualifie
les les individus De Mul voilà un peu
avant de d'évoquer donc les les
questions dans
les vous avez la la courtoisie de nous
transmettre les éléments liminires que
je voulais vous livrer et je laisse la
parole maintenant donc à au président
Abassi pour qu' qu' complète ces ces
quelques éléments introductifs merci
beaucoup oui alors euh ce qui est très
important c'est que indépendamment de
des éléments qui vous seront apportés
par euh les magistrats euh ce jour et et
en même et maintenant du parquet ou de
madame sigigala qui elle en tant que
présidente correction auss si traite des
difficultés au quotidien dans le cadre
des audiences il y a une problématique
beaucoup plus structurelle beaucoup plus
global qui n'apparaît pas dans vos
questions euh en tout cas elles y sont
peut-être de façon filigrane c'est les
moyens que l'on veut bien se donner pour
mener une une lutte qui est une lutte ou
qui serait une lutte efficace contre ce
narcotrafic donc il me semble important
d'ajouter
qu'au-delà des dispositions législative
décrétal au-delà des politiques pénales
dont le procureur et Monsieur le
substitut vous parleront bien mieux que
nous au-delà de tout cela il y a aussi
des moyens humains euh pour lutter
contre la logistique du narcotrafic il
faut que nous-même nous ayons une
logistique judiciaire efficace or euh il
y a un certain nombre d'avancées
importantes qui ont eu lieu par le biais
grâce au ministère de la Justice on en
parlera peut-être grâce à la création
notamment de brigades outrem des
magistrats et des fonctionnaires qui
viennent nous aider mais nous avons
encore besoin d'un renforcement notable
des moyens humains que ce soit au sein
du tribunal ou que ce soit euh par
l'entremise des forces de sécurité
intérieur ou de service d'enquête et
voilà donc c'est un point important à
aborder
euh la dimension humaine qui est la
seule dimension qui vaille à un moment
lorsque vous avez tous les outils qui
sont réunis
voilà
merci est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
réponde nous-même à chaque question ou
est-ce que vous voulez formuler les
questions et on vous apporte les
réponses comment souhaitez-vous procéder
messieurs les sénateurs et mesdames le
rapporteur va ouvrir avec ces questions
d'accord très bien oui merci de ces
interventions liminire j'ai une première
question vous avez appelé qu'un tiers
des vols à main armé ont lieu en Guyane
et quel lien fait-on entre ces volam
armé et le trafic de
stupéfiants
alors je vais être extrêmement modeste
extrêmement hble sur la question il y a
trois choses qui
sont tr trois points qui sont
objectivés le premier c'est
qu'eectivement on a une
augmentation de la d'appropriation de
violente de voix publ avec usage d'armes
à feu ça c'est une évidence sur
l'ensemble de la Guyane avec une
concentration sur la région de
Saint-Laurent du
Maroni l'économie de ruissellement
euh a été mécaniquement perturbé par la
politique qui a été mise en œuvre en
matière de lutte contre les stupéfiances
ça c'est très clair en tout cas en ce
qui concerne les mules après le trisème
point c'est que les mules euh qui
résident guyan et qui sont
condamnés majoritairement selon la
procédure du pldcoupable du CRPC de la
comparitiontion sur reconnaissance
préalable de culpabilité non pas du tout
le profil d'auteur de vol à armé ce qui
veut dire que je suis aujourd'hui en
tout cas incapable d'établir un lien
entre la politique qui a pu être
conduite en matière de stupéfiant et
l'augmentation des vol à armé c'est pas
du tout les mêmes profils et ça répond
pas du tout au au mêmes modes
opératoires
euh de de faire un lien entre les deux
ce serait une spéculation dans laquelle
je je veux pas me je veux pas me lancer
le l'augmentation de des volam armé de
l'emploi des armes il est partagé
régionalement puisque j'ai vu il y a il
y a un mois et demi mes collègues de de
makapa qui ont attiré aussi mon
attention sur ce phénomène qu'il
constatait eux-mêmes aussi au Brésil
donc j'aurais tendance à penser que
c'est un comportement régional euh plus
qu'un comportement directement lié avec
la la perturbation qu'on a provoqué sur
des sur le flux logistique le le la la
la mule de Saint-Laurent du Maroni ne
correspond pas du tout au profil des
gens qu'on interpelle sur des vols à
armé dans plusieurs notes au rapports
qui nous ont été remis
et on
pointe à la fois la
complexité la lourdeur et des
procédures consécutives à l'arrestation
et à l'identification des mules
et plusieurs services nous
disent c'est compliqué c'est chronophage
et et il y aurait des mesures de
simplification
nous pourrions adopter est-ce que sur ce
sujet là vous auriez des suggestions à
nous
faire la complexité
elle n'est que l'application du code de
procédure pénale
bon sauf que à partir du moment où votre
adversaire on va le qualifier
d'adversaire il est dans une politique
et dans une logique de saturation de
notre système il est très clair que on n
pas la capacité ici de placer 70 ou 80
personnes mules en garde à vue dans une
journée d'autant que de toute façon on
est limité par les capacités médicales
euh de l'hôpital qui lui n'a que cinq
chambres carcérales je vous rappelle
qu'on a un très gros établissement avec
ce matin
1032 détenus potentiellement aussi
utilisateurs de ces chambres carcérales
donc certes la procédure pénale est
complexe elle est quand même là pour
garantir au aussi le droit des
intéressés donc son application euh elle
est elle est importante dans sa totalité
euh de simplifier il y a des procédures
simplifiées qui existent qui sont
utilisées hein quand les faits sont
reconnus et cetera sauf que comme la
politique qu'on a mis en œuvre elle vise
quand même en matière de placement en
garde- à vue et de poursuite à cibler
des gens
multirécidivistes euh des gens avec des
prof profil intéressant en terme
d'enquête d'investigation des gens qui
sont très impliqués dans le trafic bah
forcément ça induit un travail euh qui
est lié à l'application du code de
procédure pénale
donc les
propositions si si on avait une
proposition concrète à faire une
modification concrète ce qui aujourd'hui
nous pénalise un peu moins ces derniers
temps parce que ça fait quelques
semaines qu'on a plus eu le cas mais
c'est des gens qui au-delà des 96 heures
de garde à vue quand ils sont retenus à
l'hôpital n'ont pas fini d'expulser les
les boulettes ce qui fait que on est
obligé de procéder un défermement à
l'hôpital avec une procédure de
comparution à délis différés euh
d'intervention du JLD à l'hôpital et
d'engagement des poursuites qui est
relativement lourde euh alors
effectivement si on pouvait avoir un une
une prolongation une hyperprolongation
médicale au-delà des 96 he prévu par la
loi pour ces cas de figure des gens qui
n'ont pas fini d'expulser effectivement
ça nous simplifierait la tâche et je
pense que en tout cas de de du côté de
de l'action publique et du parquet et de
la juridiction c'est sûrement la chose
qui est la aujourd'hui la plus
pénalisante et qui pourrait utilement
évoluer peut-être juste côté siège
c'est-à-dire côté juge attention de ne
pas créer des zones dérogatoires de
droit parce que c'est la Guyane ça c'est
vraiment important nous sommes dans une
politique régionale entouré de pays qui
ont fait le choix de procédure
extrêmement rapide pour ne pas dire
expéditive et du côté du tribunal
correctionnel nous nous entendons aussi
faire en sorte que les droits soient
respectés l'allègement la simplification
de la procédure ne doit pas ne doivent
pas avoir pour corollaire une opération
des droits de tous à pouvoir être
entendu examiner à pouvoir voir tous
leurs droits notifiés dans les temps et
donc euh l'action publique très bien
décrite par monsieur le procureur doit
donner lieu à un moment un passage
devant le tribunal et euh madame Sigala
qui euh juge régulièrement ces personnes
voir les juges d'instruction qui sont à
la manœuvre aussi savent à quel point il
est important euh de pouvoir répondre
aux critiques des avocats euh qui
pourrai faire annuler des procédures et
je terminerai juste en parlant des
standards européens euh qui ne nous
permettrait pas non plus d'appliquer
parce que c'est la Guyane un régime
dérogatoire voilà moi je je crois que
que c'est important de souligner je sais
pas si Madame Sigala souhaite ajouter
quelque chose non Mo je suis tout à fait
d'accord effectivement c'est pas tant la
procédure pénale qui qui qui nous pose
problème ici et puis il me semble que
les mules sont identifiables puisqu'il
s'agit souvent de jeunes
guyané qui sont dans des situations très
très précaires enfin moi les gens les
gens que je vois qui sont déférés devant
moi quand je suis de permanence le
weekend ou que je juge ensuite au
tribunal c'est des gens qui sont
identifiables en Guyane c'est des jeunes
des fois qui sont on nous avait parlé
d'une liste d'attente à la sortie du du
du collège de Saint-Laurent du Maroni
pour faire la mule donc c'est des guyané
qui sont
identifiables dans dans la question que
je posé il était pas du tout question
d'avoir une procédure spécifique et
spéciale pour la Guyane c'est évident et
la question que je posais c'est que la
lutte contre les mules entraîne un
certain nombre de contraintes qui sont
des contraintes extrêmement lourdes vous
en avez cité une c'est le délai pendant
lequel la personne est placée à
l'hôpital pour que l'on puisse s'assurer
que lorsqu'elle sort elle n'a plus sur
elle de stupéfiants qui ont été ingérés
c'est bien ce à quoi je pensais et c'est
aussi tout tout le dispositif de
surveillance de ces personnes
lorsqu'elles sont placées à l'hôpital
donc on vous a bien entendu sur le délai
qui pourrait passer de tro 5 jours enfin
je pense que ça serait quelque chose de
raisonnable et et et en dehors
de cette suggestion cette proposition
d'amélioration est-ce qu'il y aura
d'autres pistes notamment pour les
moyens matériels et les moyens humains
et qui
sont mis en œuvre en raison de C tr
attention à
l'hôpital alors les les les moyens
aujourd'hui ce qui est dimensionnant
effectivement c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous évoquez c'est la capacité de
l'hôpital à
accueillir les mules le temps de
l'expulsion du produitin on avait
été quand on a il y a un an on avait été
au Pays-Bas on avait été à l'aéroport de
de de tripole effectivement là on a
découvert un établissement
pénitentiaire avec trois étages de
cellules avec tous les moyens dont on
peut
rêver au sein même du du site de
l'aéroport on on ne dispose pas de de
ces moyensl à
Cayenne donc c'est totalement
dimensionnant et et est toujours en
miroir bien sûr avec la stratégie de nos
adversaires qui elle est une stratégie
de de nous de nous saturer puisque par
que les les les jours les les plus gros
pics qu'on a eu on a eu jusqu'à 80 mules
le dimanche
après-midi qui essayent d'embarquer sur
le le le vol Air Caraïb après après
avoir fait celui d'Air France voilà mais
c'est certain que ce qui alors il y a
deux choses dimensionnantes il y a
certes les capacités euh médicales
euh d'accueil donc de de ces personnees
plac en garde à vue l'autre chose qui
est dimensionnante quand même c'est la
durée du contrôle euh on est au départ
on ne peut on peut difficilement exiger
à un passager qu'il se présente 5 ou 6
he avant pour qu'on procède à des
contrôles approfondis euh voilà euh on
n'est pas les gens accepteraient je
pense sur une menace terroriste euh les
gens n'acceptent les passagers
n'accepteraient pas de venir 5h avant ou
6h avant pour être pour pour être
contrôlé dans cette dans ce domaine-là
donc on a ces contrainteslà ici qui sont
inhérentes au fait on est un lieu de
départ et qu'on n pas un lieu d'arrivée
voilà c'est peut-être plus facile de
mettre ça en œuvre sur un lieu d'arrivée
que sur un lieu de départ pour
information un contrôle individuel ça
prend combien de
temps
euh dans le processus euh pour les gens
qui sont ciblés
euh s'ils sont rapidement disculpé la
chose doit pas durer plus de plus de 15
ou 20
minutes
merci pour être clair que si l'on veut
raccourcir ses délais et augmenter le
nombre de personnes contrôlées ça passe
par plus de matériel et plus de points
de
contrôle tout à fait il faudrait des il
faudrait des moyens humains et surtout
et surtout vous imaginez une capacité
euh de mettre entre 50 et et 100
personnes garde à vue quotidiennement
euh ça nécessite des moyens
considérables et et surtout euh combien
même on aurait ces moyens qu' qu'on
pourrait rêver avoir ces moyens de toute
façon notre adversaire est dans une
politique de saturation donc je mets 50
policiers de plus à l'aéroport ils vont
mettre 50 mules de plus pour nous
saturer depuis le départ leur stratégie
c'est une stratégie de saturation ils
vont attendre sur le parking la dernière
minute pour pour essayer d'embarquer de
saturer les gens qui sont à l'accueil de
saturer le personnel de l'aéroport voilà
cette surenchère par définition on la
perdra puisque eux ils ont des moyens
financiers et humains illimités par
rapport au nres donc donc c'est pour ça
que l'approche on l'a on l'a envisagé
différemment parce que on était dans
cette surenchère et et on était perdant
par définition
ce trafic génère des flux financiers
et qui peuvent prendre plusieurs formes
et aujourd'hui quels sont les
dispositifs que vous meta en place pour
contrôler la situation matérielle la
situation financière d'un certain nombre
de familles je parle des mules si je
parle de leurs proches de leur contact
de leur relation et comment est-ce que
vous vous attaquez à ces
réseaux alors il y a un premier travail
qui est fait déjà à l'aéroport sur le
retour puisque les les douanes là donc
ont investi ce ce champ euh et donc sur
le retour pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée euh donc de
novembre sur les 11 derniers mois donc
de novembre l'année dernière à septembre
cette année on a saisi sur le retour 405
50000 € ce qui est quand même pas une
somme négligeable et qui correspond donc
au entre guillemets salaires des mules
qui
reviennent qui reviennent en Guan sur la
totalité de 2022 il y avait eu 627000 €
qui avaient été qui avait été saisis ça
c'est la première étape c'est la
première sanction je dirais financière
ensuite aujourd'hui avec le renforcement
de l'ofast
euh et puis de la PAF à Saint-Laurent du
Maroni parce que c'est essentiel ement
de l'xe on régénère les mules mais pas
que on a la capacité d'une
part d'aller procéder tout de suite à
une perquisition et puis d'autre part
effectivement de faire un travail
d'investigation sur les sur les revenus
de la personne après il est très clair
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai pas les moyens
d'investigation pour regarder faire la
la la partie financière de la totalité
des mules qui sont qui sont pour Ju est
condamné pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée on est passé de 161 mules en 2021
à 486 sur les 11 derniers mois placé en
garde à vue et poursuivi on na pas les
moyens d'investigation pour faire un
dossier financier sur chacune de ces
personnes par contre on a maintenant le
moyen de faire un travail d'essayer
d'identifier ces réseaux guyanais qui
sont en fin de compte des des des micro
réseaux euh on est sur des des
structures communautaires qui sont pas
pas si étendu que ça et là on peut faire
le travail là-dessus et de mémoire euh
l'ofaste actuellement en tout cas la
dernière fois qu'on m'a fait un point
donc début novembre avait une une
cinquantaine une petite cinquantaine
d'enquête en cours dans ce
domaineel marieelur finera
or merci président bonsoir messieurs
dames alors je voudrais m'adresser à
Monsieur le Procureur à Monsieur Yv
Leclerc alors j'ai deux trois questions
bon c'est simplement pour faire avancer
en fait faire comprendre à la commission
ce qui est déjà fait pour
pouvoir enrichir notre notre rapport de
juillet à septembre 2022 vous avez tenté
une expérience je rappelle que les
saisies de moins de 1, 5 étaient classé
sans suite afin de diminuer la charge
pénale pouvez-vous dresser un rapide
bilan de cette action pouvez-vous nous
dire également si les contrôles 100 % et
les arrêtés préfectoraux antimul ont
réussi à perturber le trafic de
stupéfiants et enfin pensez-vous qu'un
scanner qui permette de relever les
objets ingérés à l'instar de chipol
permettra de porter un coup dur au
trafic et puis Président si si tu
permets je voudrais aussi poser une
question à monsieur le Président du
tribunal judiciaire monsieur Abbassi en
septembre 2022 le garde des saau Éric
Dupont avait annoncé l'envoi en Guyane
de brigade de renfort afin de palier le
manque d'effectif au tribunal ces
renforts vous ont-ils permis d'améliorer
le traitement judiciaire et faut-il
péréniser ses renforts il y a 2 ans
également j'avais interpellé le ministre
de la Justice en QAG car j'estimais et
d'ailleurs je l'estime toujours que la
Guyane mérite de disposer d'une geersce
qui lui est propre afin de mieux lutter
contre le trafic de stupéfiants euh je
sais pas si je vous oblige à sortir de
votre réserve mais j'aimerais bien
connaître votre avis je vous remercie
messieur merci une question d'Olivier
cadiic oui ça ça va compléter ce que
vient de dire ma collègue parce que
c'est vrai que on Nimagine pas que
d'avoir 50 terroristes qui puisse venir
avec des explosifs arrivver devant un
avion et puis que on en laisse on en
arrête quelques-uns et qu'on dise qu'on
puisse être déborder et que donc donc
voilà donc ça mettrait en en péril la
sécurité de évidemment de de l'avion là
c'est vrai que ce ce système qui qui
vient avec un nombre de mules qui
déborde nos services et puis ça ça passe
c'est c'est un peu dérouttant je pense
que vous pouvez le le comprendre et ce
qui fait que mettre plus de moyens c'est
vrai que certains nous ont parlé d'un
système qui permette de voir
automatiquement si de la drogue était
ingérée on voit que aux Antilles ça nous
a été dit hier que de plus en plus il
voit ce phénomène se développer donc ça
prend du temps une fois que on arrête
quelqu'un qui a de la drogue ingérée
effectivement il faut des moyens aussi
médicaux pour accompagner donc tout ça
ça prend énormément de temps on le
comprend mais ne pensez-vous pas que
justement la solution ce soit d'avoir un
système qui permet de contrôler tout le
monde pour voir s'il a ingéré de la
drogue en montant dans la avant de
monter dans l'avion et qu'on le stoppe à
cet endroit-là et que on met en place
des procédures parce que ça paraît c'est
difficilement audible pour nous dans
l'Hexagone de se dire que on a x
personnes qui montent dans chaque avion
parce que on n'est pas capable d'arrêter
tout le monde c'est il y a bien une
question de process qu'il faut qu'on
mette en place pour voilà pour voir
comment on arrête ce flot et puis
j'ajoute ma
question on a eu l'autre jour lundi lors
de des tables ronds de de magistrats de
pour la zone Guadeloupe Martinique Des
propos assez assez dur sur la qualité de
la coopération entre services offast
douan parfois même entre service de
l'ofast voilà donc je voulais aussi vous
solliciter sur ce sujet
oui alors pour répondre à la première
question sur la la la phase voà la
fameuse histoire du 1,5 qui avait
instrumentalisé par par par par par
certains médias pas forc ent très
bienveillant c'est effectivement une
phase exploratoire où dans des documents
internes on avait pourquoi 1,5 parce
qu'en fin de compte c'était la quantité
qu'on avait de façon traditionnelle
incorporée et qu'on avait décidé de
d'évaluer la avec le préfet de l'époque
la potentialité de de recourir donc de
façon beaucoup plus importante aux
arrêtés
administratifs plutôt qu'à exercer des
poursuites voilà donc le le le le
l'histoire de d'un,5 c'était uniquement
ça il a jamais été question de
déjudiciariser quoi que ce soit en
matière de stupéfiant la preuve c'est
que de sur une année on a augmenté de
200 plus de 200 % vous le verrez dans ma
réponse écrite j'ai fait le calcul
quasiment 230 % le nombre de gardes à vu
bon donc sur ce sur ce pointlà voilà
euh les 100 % mules donc cet outils
administ ratif qui quand même euh vise à
empêcher une personne de se mettre en
danger euh puisqu'on l'empêche de de
monter dans un aéronef avec le risque
que les une de ces boulettes éclate
entraînant la mort instantanéément euh
donc effectivement c'est notre bouclier
c'est-à-dire que c'est ce qui permet euh
et bien de de de d'être à la hauteur de
la stratégie de nos adversaires de
saturation euh par un moyen qui est
souple euh et qui a permis de de bloquer
un certain nombre de gens hein les
forces de l'ordre ont dû vous donner le
le chiffre c'est assez c'est assez
impressionnant et avec aujourd'hui
euh une évolution euh
ben qui est en tout cas à ce stade
favorable
euh qui va mériter d'être affiné dans
les semaines dans les mois venir mais
euh depuis aller depuis début novembre
on a un
effondrement du nombre de mules alors il
y a pas de mules qui se dirige vers
roissi on essae actuellement d'essayer
de comprendre pourquoi
euh et on a une baisse très sensible des
mules avec la disparition de filières
euh on avait au départ des des filières
baltes qui ont complètement disparu
assez rapidement c'est les gens ont dû
se réarticuler sur d'autres itinéraires
et là plus récemment parce que on a
quand même fait un bras de fer pendant
des mois avec la filière nigériane qui
arrivait jusqu'à essayer de mettre 100
personnes par par dimanche où là tout
d'un coup depuis quelques semaines les
seuls nigériens qui restent c'est ceux
qui sont bloqués ici et qu'on est en
train d'évacuer au comptegoutte euh pour
les pour les faire reconduire voilà euh
donc bah un dispositif en fin de compte
qui
fonctionne et qui voilà qui qui va
mériter d'être affiné mais on a on a
effectivement provoqué quelque chose
euh le scanner alors honnêtement on a
écarté cette solution
ici d'une part en raison de ce que
j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure de la durée
qui nous a accordé pour contrôler les
gens un scanner c'est un acte médical en
plus donc donc il nous faut une
structure médicale ça prend beaucoup de
temps on peut pas passer même si on a
deux vols qui sont qui sont étalés sur
4h on peut pas passer 5 ou 600 personnes
au scanner dans la durée qui nous est
impartie d'autant que de façon plus
stratégique si ce qu'on essaie de faire
va au bout et et fonctionne et on a
quand même quelques indicateurs la
pertinence du scanner il est pas au
départ il est à l'arrivée c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait les Néerlandais
les Néerlandais le scanner il est pas à
Paramaribo il est au Pays-Bas euh parce
que là ils ont le temps à l'arrivée de
bah de d'essayer de localiser des des
individus et les placer en garde à vue
et puis de procéder l'examen médical
donc le scanner ici pour moi il est pas
pertinent on a testé deux euh deux
modèles de yon scan c'est-à-dire des
appareils qui euh essae de détecter des
molécules de cocaïne sur les mains euh
appareils qui sont aussi utilisés
d'ailleurs en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme sur les euh ça n'a pas
fonctionné est-ce que est-ce qu'on a un
trop gros niveau de d'humidité euh voilà
le le les fabricants nous disaient que
ça fonctionnait en Europe bon on a testé
ici ça fonctionne pas donc donc on a on
a écarté aussi ça mais pour moi le
scanner euh il faut le mettre sur les
aéroports parisiens d'autant que donc
vous avez évoqué la question vous avez
eu nos collègues de fort- de- France le
mécanisme de contournement est en train
de de de de se faire nous on a fait deux
essais de contrôle 100 % sur de vols
Fort de France sur 150 passagers on
avait 10 mules à chaque fois donc il y a
bien il y a bien des filières qui
essayent de de procéder à un
contournement alors qui pour pour ces
organisations là vont être plus complexe
je pense c'est pour ça qu' sont
peut-être moins nombreux parce qu'il
leur faut forcément une base logistique
de rebond pour réingérer les les les les
ovules aux Antilles ce qui nécessite bah
que ces gens-là aient des complicités
trouvent des hôtels et cetera et cetera
voilà euh donc scanner sur la région
parisienne pour répondre à la question
sur laagirs euh en définitive dans la
circulaire de de politique pénale que
j'ai que j'ai évoqué le gardessau avait
décidé de la création non pas d'une ge
parce que là il faudrait je pense
modifier le code de l'organisation
judiciaire et le code de procédure
pénale parce qu'ils sont prévus dans des
textes mais de façon très pragmatique à
demandé à ce que soit créée une division
délinquence organisé ce qui est le cas
au sein de mon parquet puisque et
monsieur Alexandre roussle Magri et un
des un des des des trois magistrats de
cette division là on a depuis le mois de
septembre on avait même un peu anticipé
créer cette fameuse division qui global
ement à en tout cas au niveau du parquet
une activité identique à celle à celle
d'une à celle d'une JS voilà dernier
point sur la coopération entre les
services de police
euh bah elle est ce qu'elle est ici à
l'aéroport ça fonctionne très bien parce
qu'en définitive chacun a trouvé sa
passe la
PAF est attentif aux individus la douane
est attentive aux valises et au fret on
a essayé de renvoyer chacun nager dans
sa ligne d'eau euh et faire ce qui sait
faire le mieux euh voilà donc c'est
l'oface qui récupère derrière les
individus interpellés et qui fait les
les enquêtes en sachant que la stratégie
quand même même et je rentrerai pas dans
les détails vous comprendrez pourquoi
euh cette stratégie de de 100 % mul nous
a permis un travail de fond extrêmement
intéressant euh sur les les
compromissions aéroportuaires voilà ça
c'est très clair certaines dossiers ont
déjà été jugé d'autres d'autres dossiers
sont à l'instruction ici est en et en
métropole euh quand vous mettez un
système sousension forcément euh et bien
apparaissent euh des compromissions dans
tout un tas de services de prestataires
de services aéroportuaires et c'est
surtout ça qui est intéressant puisqu'on
revient à mon mon mon propos liminaire
qui est de porter des coûts aux
logisticiens de l'exportation du du
produit voilà est-ce que ça répond à
l'intégralité de vos questions ou si
vous voulez d'autres j'ai peut-être
oublié certaines
questions moi je je je vais répondre à
la sénatrice oui poser des questions euh
peut-être juste avant parce qu'on a la
chance d'avoir aussi des collègues qui
sont encore plus que nous dans le
terrain je sais pas si Monsieur rousle
Magri ve ajouter quelque
chose je vous remercie monsieur je vous
remercie monsieur le Président euh euh
bonjour euh euh mesdames les sénatrices
et et et monsieurs les sénateur je je
rajouterai pas grand-chose à ce qu'a
déjà dit Monsieur Monsieur le Procureur
de la République et puis avant lui
monsieur le Président euh simplement
souligner euh euh par rapport moi je
comprends he le le le l'interrogation de
monsieur le sénateur sur euh la
comparaison avec les 50 terroristes
qu'on ne laisserait pas euh embarquer
euh dans dans un aéronef euh en réalité
la difficulté et c'est la stratégie qui
qui a été mise en place par Monsieur le
Procureur en réponse c'est que nous
menons une guerre de logisticiens à des
logisticiens euh
et le le le produit ne prend sa
véritable valeur qu'une fois qu'il a
traversé l'Atlantique et qu'il se
retrouve sur le territoire européen de
la France moi je le vois que ce soit
dans le cadre de la permanence générale
du parquet de
Cayenne ou dans le cadre de le dossier
de criminalité organisée en réalité il
faut bien prendre conscience qu'il y a
un vivier euh je pas dire illimité mais
mais mais un vivier comprenant de de
très nombreux individus qui sont prêts à
risquer d'une part leur vie et puis
d'autre part une lourde sanction pénale
avec potentiellement de la de la
détention de la détention euh pour les
quelques milliers d'euros qui leur sont
qui leur sont promis par les trafiquants
de stupéfiant et comme l'a rappelé
madame la première vice-présidente en
charge du pôle pénal ce sont des gens
qui vivent des minimas sociaux
généralement et donc qui qui se
retrouent avec avec qui peuvent être
facilement séduit par par les promesses
d'argent facile pour compléter les
propos de Monsieur le Procureur et pour
répondre à la question néanmoins de de
de ce qui est mise en place sur les
circuits financiers
euh il existe des dossiers des affaires
que nous traitons en blanchiment hein de
de trafic de stupéfiant via l'infraction
spécifique qui est prévu par le code
pénal à deux niveaux le premier niveau
c'est celui bah des transporteuses et
des transporteurs de cocaïne qui
reviennent en guyan et qui souvent
achètent des biens de consommation
euh que ce soit des véhicules haut de
gamme et et et des et des des des
vêtements de luxe et des biens de
consommation euh téléphone portable
assez cher et ce genre de bien les
services de de police et de gendarmerie
travaillent à tous les
niveaux à titre d'exemple j'ai déjà pu
moi personnellement faire des dossiers
de blanchiment de trafic de stupéfiants
avec des brigades motorisées de
gendarmerie qui qui comme point de
départ des contrôles routiers donc c'est
des choses qui se font et jusqu'à bien
entendu des services beaucoup plus
spécialisés type police judiciaire
ofast et section de recherche la
difficulté je rejoint ce qu' dit
monsieur le Président et je m'arrêterai
là sur mon propos c'est
que il y a une capacité d'enquête avec
des moyens limité en terme d'enquête
mais il y a aussi une nécessité de
pouvoir juger euh ces personnesl et le
le créneau d'audience si vous me
permettez l'expression au tribunal
judiciaire de Cayenne est extrêmement
cher euh et on l'a vu
lorsque nous avons des dossiers qui sont
menés que ce soit par les services de
police ou les services de gendarmerie et
nous arrivons à démler des réseaux de 10
15 20 personnes qui
sont prévenu peu importe le choix de
poursuite qui est fait par le ministère
public que ce soit la voie de
l'ouverture de l'information judiciaire
ou que ce soit la voie de de comparution
à délis différés ou de compartion
immédiate devant le tribunal
correctionnel c'est une logistique qui
est extrêmement compliquée à mettre en
œuvre car là nous passons d'une
saturation des services d'enquête à une
saturation des services judiciaires dans
leur capacit
à
traiter ce ce type d'affair dans des
délais qui soient raisonnaablees qui
respectent les exigence en matière de
présomption d'innocence et de détention
provisoire voilà ce que ce que j'aurais
à dire juste pour simplement compléter
les propos qui ont déjà pu être tenus
oui si je peux
rajouter
d'accordoui si je peux rajouter juste
quelque chose sur ce manque de moyen
parce que je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant de notre situation euh pour
juger un dossier de de narcotrafiquant
encore faut-il que le dossier soit
préparé quand c'est un vrai dossier
important il y a normalement un juge
d'instruction qui est nommé donc je
rappellerai qu'à
Cayenne actuellement nous avons quatre
cabinets
d'instruction nous avons fait la moyenne
elles sont actuellement à plus de 142
dossiers par cabinet je rappelle que la
moyenne de pour bien travailler pour
qu'un juge d'instruction puisse faire un
dossier correctement dans de bons délais
on parlait de des délais de détention
provisoire et des délais pour sortir un
dossier l'Association française des
magistrats instructeur à a fixé le
chiffre à 70 dossiers donc depuis très
très longtemps maintenant nous demandons
la création d'un 5e cabinet de juge
d'instruction donc un 5èe juginstruction
que nous n'avons toujours pas obtenu
nous avons obtenu effectivement des
renforts avec des brigad les magistrats
qui viennent pour 6 mois un jour bon
comme ils prennent des congés ou qu'
sont en stage finalement ils viennent 5
mois sur place réellement sur la
première brigade nous avons eu quatre
magistrats en renfort sur la deuxème
nous en avons trois donc ce qui est pas
ce qui n'est pas assez puisque je
rappellerai qu'à Cayenne on a un chiffre
de vacan de poste le plus important de
France il faut le savoir puce qu'en fait
quand on dit manque de moyens il faut
aussi que vous ayez les vrais chiffres
pour pouvoir comprendre dans quel
désarrois nous sommes pour pouvoir
effectivement assumer complètement no
notre notre notre office à Cayen nous
n'avons pas de chambre pénale dédiée
c'est-à-dire que il y a pas assez de
magistrat dédiés au pôle pénal pour
pouvoir juger toutes ces affaires et
nous sommes obligés d'employer les
magistrats civilistes et tous les
magistrats spécialisés fondu pénal je
n'ai pas une chambre spéciale pénale
pour pouvant donc juger ces ces grosses
affaires alors de temps enfant de temps
en temps effectivement sur des gros
dossiers on va se donner les moyens on
va créer une audience par exemple de 2
TR jours quand on a en en face de nous
effectivement un dossier où il y a 10
délinquants on est obligé de créer des
audiences euh on peut pas juger ça en
une après-midi donc on va créer des
audiences dédiées on appelle ça des
audiences spéciales on n' pas les moyens
de le faire de manière de manière
régulière parce que avec le manque de
magistrat du siège he s'ajoute aussi le
manque chronique de greffier qui ne
peuvent pas assumer de toute façon les
tâches que ce soit la tenue des
audiences la rédaction des jugement puis
ensuite l'exécution des
peines merci Madame juste juste en
complément de ce
peut-être juste pour pour terminer sur
la question de madame la sénatrice
euh monsieur le garde des saau avait
promis la création de brigades les
brigades ont bien été créées elles nous
ont bien été affectées selon les
modalités précisées par Madame Sigala
mais il faut savoir qu'on aura toujours
un temps de retard on sera toujours en
décalage par rapport à un accroissement
de la délin et euh la seule possibilité
véritablement d'aboutir à un résultat
qui soit un résultat adéquat
c'est-à-dire d'être en osmose avec ce
qu'appelait tout à l'heure Monsieur le
Procureur nos adversaires alors nous
pour nous on les considère comme des
justiciables point mais il faut
effectivement euh une véritable prise en
en compte et une sorte de de plan
Marshal des ressources humaines à
Cayenne qui est prise en compte je le
dis par la Chancellerie puisque nous
avons également au sein du ministère de
la Justice un véritable écho nous avons
un écho de leur part et nous savons que
le ministère souhaite vraiment nous
apporter une aide je terminerai juste
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs en
évoquant un point c'est
l'attractivité on peut créer 5 10 15 20
postes si nous n'augmentons pas et si
nous ne nous prenons pas des mesures
d'attractivité fortes pour recruter des
magistrats les faire venir et
fonctionnaires et des contractuels aussi
on a beau passé de 30 à 50 magistrats du
siège vous pourrez les proposer mais les
magistrats du siège pourraient ne pas
postuler voilà donc il y a un effort qui
est fait pour répondre encore une fois à
madame la sénatrice mais nous avons
besoin aussi d'être plus attractif et ça
c'est toute une problématique qui touche
pas seulement l'institution judiciaire
mais toutes les institutions
administratives de de guyan voilà est-ce
que vous pouvez décliner cette cet
argument là qui paraît extrêmement
important de l'attractivité les mesures
auxquelles vous
pensez alors aujourd'hui quand vous
venez en guyan on va faire je crois que
pour mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le rapporteur blanc
il faut que vous ayez conscience que un
magistrat quand il vient en guyan il est
dans trois options possibles soit il
sort de l'École nationale de la
magistrature on on propose donc à des
jeunes mag aucune expérience de nous
rejoindre on a la chance d'avoir de plus
en plus des jeunes magistrats de qualité
qui acceptent de venir nous voir mais
imaginez à quel point ça peut être dur
pour eux c'est le cas de Monsieur rousle
Magri que vous avez en face de vous qui
est sortant d'école et qui a très vite
appris et appr pris les les rouages
guané qui sont pas simples c'est une
partie non négligeable des magistrats en
guyan ces auditeurs de justice comme on
les appelle il faut aussi mettre en
place une mesure d' attractivité parce
qu'il ne faut pas que ce soit les
derniers je rassure monsieur rousl Magri
loin d'être le dernier de sa promotion
bien au contraire mais il ne faut pas
que ce soit les derniers des promotions
et pour se faire la Chancellerie a créé
un contrat de mobilité qui est un un un
contrat très intéressant qui permet à
dire qu'un magistrat notamment un
sortant d'école qui vient en Guyane a la
possibilité de choisir cinq fonctions
pour lui permettre de revenir dans de
bonnes conditions lorsqu'il quitterait
la
deuxème option après l'école nationale
de la magistrature vous avez les
magistrats d'expérience et en réalité
nous ne sommes pas suffisamment
attractifs parce que mis à part les 40 %
d'augmentation sur la base d'un calcul
savant que la DG FIP seul est en mesure
de comprendre
elle-même les mesures
attractives d'allègement fiscal et
autres ne suffisent plus du tout et il y
a un très bon rapport d'ailleurs qui a
été fait par la Cour des comptes de
septembre 202 23 qui évoque ces mesures
d'attractivité qui disent que les
mesures actuelles ne sont pas
suffisantes donc cette option des
magistrats d'expérience elle ne marche
pas et nous avons en guyan très peu de
magistrats qui sont des magistrats qui
ont 10 ou 15 ans d'expérience madame
Sigala est un exemple intéressant mais
elle est venue aussi parce qu'elle
voulait occuper et changer un petit peu
son quotidien et enfin la troisème
option qui est peut-être la plus
importante pour moi c'est de faire en
sorte que vous vous ayez en en
encadrement intermédiaire des collègues
qui arrivent avec des postes
intéressants alors en mesure
d'attractivité c'est très simple le haut
le haut du pavé de de la magistrature
française c'est ce qu'on appelle les
hors hiérarchie et pour être intéressant
de développer ces postes hors
hiérarchie actuellement nous n'avons que
deux postes hors hiérarchie au tribunal
judiciaire de Cayenne c'est le procureur
et moi-même c'est les deux seuls postes
si on l'ouvrait un un un peu le volant
de ces postes hors hiérarchie vous
auriez des candidats beaucoup plus
nombreux pour venir apporter leur
expérience et être au soutien des plus
jeunes magistrats voilà quelques mesures
d'attractivité qui peuvent être
intéressantes et enfin je terminerai par
des problématiques plus globales
d'immobilier d'accompagnement des
familles d'accompagnement en terme de
sécurité aussi qui manque cruellement
aujourd'hui travailler pour une société
privée anguane est beaucoup plus
réconfortant rassurant que de travailler
pour une institution publique sachez que
lorsque l'on arrive même s'il y a eu des
améliorations nous devons chercher
nous-mêmes de où o nous loger ça c'est
la première chose et nous n'avons pas
contrairement à d'autres institutions
des logements de fonction nous nen avons
pas voilà donc je crois que en
attractivité il y a des choses à faire
le ministère de la Justice nous le
savons travaille d'arrachepied pour ça
mais mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous avons également besoin de des
parlementaire voilà je crois que votre
rôle est très très important parce
que nous sommes confrontés à des
blocages qui sont des blocages légaux ou
réglementaires qui éviteraient peut-être
de débloquer des situations et d'être
encore plus attractif voilà j'espère
enfin on espère avoir répondu sur ce
point une question sur la coopération
internationale comment la
jugez-vous alors on a une une très bonne
coopération avec nos camarades
brésiliens puisque nous avons un centre
de coopération policier pas policiers
douaniier uniquement policier donc à
Saint-Georges de l'oyapocque au sein
duquel donc on a des des policiers et
gendarmes et de l'autre côté donc la
police fédérale la police militaire et
et la police
routière brésilienne voilà les échanges
sont extrêmement fructueux et très
honnêtement grâce à la police fédérale
on a énormément progressé sur
l'identification des factionnés
Brésiliens et euh et pour vous donner un
ord d'idée euh de la bienveillance de
nos collègues même si c'est dans un
autre domaine j'ai un officier de la
police donc militaire brésilienne qui
est venue de makapa un aller-retour
makapa Cayen c'est 20h de VO ure pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée et pour
venir attirer mon attention sur le fait
que ils avaient détecté des une faction
extrêmement inquiétante le PCC qui est
une faction très
active sur la région de camopie et qui
est en train de s'installer sur de la
logistique de leur paillage et sur du
transit de de de stupéfiant donc vous
voyez nos nos amis brésiliens sont
extrêmement bienveillant on a des outils
de de coopération
euh policières judiciaire et là notre
sujet actuellement de de travail avec
eux c'est d'essayer de faire purger les
peines de factionnés Brésiliens qui sont
détenus ici au Brésil et surtout pas et
surtout pas c'est un enjeu majeur
surtout pas de les renvoyer en France
pour qu'ils purgent des longues peines
parce que les premiers qui sont arrivés
en
métropole ne sont pas repartis au Brésil
et sont partis sur des activités
criminelles ext inquiétante et quand on
met au sein de la prison et même pour
certains qui sont sortis donc qui font
l'objet d'une très grande vigilance
parce qu'on a l'exemple du Portugal où
les factions brésiliennes ont pris le
contrôle des trafics de stupéfiants de
extrêmement rapidement et donc il il y a
une vraie menace donc ça c'est du côté
brésilien ça fonctionne très bien du
côté
Surinam bah là on est en attente de
ratification des accords de coopération
judiciaire
euh bon allez on va être politiquement
correct je dirais que notre niveau de
collaboration s'arrête au niveau de
compromission auquel on peut se heurter
dans certains services de police ou ou
en tout cas de suspici de compromission
auquel on peut on peut se heurter le
Surinam est quand même un pays dans
lequel malheureusement le trafic de
cocaïne est très fortement implanté donc
voilà on on essaie ess de collaborer
avec eux la semaine dernière il y a une
mission qui est partie là-bas ils ont
attiré notre attention sur le fait qu'il
détectait massivement des gens
originaires de Saint-Laurent du Maroni
qui essayaient de prendre l'avion à
Paramaribo donc on a bien compris que
notre notre politique fonctionnait que
les gens sont sur un une impasse de
contournement là-bas voilà mais mais
c'est plus complexe maintenant on avance
petit à petit par exemple il y a des des
je sais qu'il y a des patrouilles
communes sur le Maroni maintenant de
nuits entre la PAF et puis la la la
police militaire surinamienne voilà il
se passe des choses mais je dirait que
c'est pas du tout au même niveau que un
grand pays une grande puissance
continentale qu le Brésil fédérale
certes mais extrêmement bienveillante
avec nous voilà sur la coopération
internationale moi je je serais un peu
moins positif que Monsieur le Procureur
de la République s'agissant des
commissions rogatoires des juges
d'instruction qui ont parfois beaucoup
de mal à être exécuté au Brésil beaucoup
de mal
et la coopération judiciaire à ce
niveau-là n'est pas toujours à la
hauteur de ce que l'on peut attendre et
nous appelons régulièrement de nouveux
un renforcement des liens entre
l'ambassade des ambassades le ministère
des affaires étrangères de la justice et
les magistrats de liaison le magistrat
de liaison donc je tenais juste à vous
dire que un certain nombre de
commissions rogatoires encore une fois
en matière de stupléfiant n'ont
malheureusement pas pu
revenir de façon positive et fructueuse
voilà donc je dirais que la coopération
elle est excellente dès qu'elle part du
terrain c'est dire que les les relations
sont excellentes entre les le parquet ou
les parquetiers brésiliens ou ou avec la
police quelle qu'elle soit elle devient
plus complexe quand elle
s'institutionnalise au niveau des
ambassades du ministère où pour le coup
on rentre dans quelque chose de beaucoup
plus nébuleux long euh fastidieux à
telle enseigne pour terminer que
certains juges d'instruction disent he
qu'il finissent par préférer ne pas
attendre le retour d'une commission
rogatoire pour ne pas que le dossier
puisse se perdre dans les limbes de leur
cabinet voilà donc c'est le le temp le
le le le tempérament que j'apporte au
propos de Monsieur le Procureur juste
une petite précision géographique si
vous regardez une carte vous verrez que
l'État donc d'Amapa avec sa capitale
makapa et n'est pas relié au reste du
Brésil par la route la seule route qui a
cet état c'est une route avec la Guyane
voilà et pour aller de de de makapa donc
jusqu'à la frontière yapquet jusqu'à
nous il y a 10 ou 12 heur de piste euh
donc vous imaginez voilà les les
contraintes que ça génère et les gens
qui sont à maapa sont tournés vers nous
avec bienveillance mais ne peuvent même
pas aller par la route dans le reste du
Brésil donc donc vous imaginez Rio euh
c'est c'est souvent plus rapide d'aller
à Dakar d'ici que de la province de
forte-alaise les provinces les plus au
sud de du Brésil c'est un état continent
voilà il nous reste à vous remercier
très chaleureusement pour la qualité de
cette audition des informations que vous
nous avez transmises et puis
de du climat en plus technique très
favorable parce qu'on a eu un peu de mal
pour les auditions précédentes qui
étaient parfois peine audiblebl donc
merci de de de votre présence ses
réponses et puis on compte sur les
questionnaires écrits qui compléteront
ce qu'on s'est dit si vous le voulez
bien écoutez nous nous vous remercions
également le questionnaire est parti à
votre collaboratrice avec les avec un
peu plus et bien entendu si mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs souhaitent venir
voir sur place
euh dans quelle situation nous sommes
euh vous serez les bienvenus notre notre
sénatrice bien sûr connait connais bien
Laan puisqu'elle y a à domicile mais je
pense que voilà de vous accueillir que
vous preniez toute la mesure que nous
sommes en Amérique du Sud confronté à
des des problématiques sud-américaines
certaines fois peut peut être surprenant
un grand
merciinitation merci d'invitation je
suis pas sûr qu'on puisse l'honorer
parce qu'on a beaucoup de travaill ici
en métropole beaucoup de déplacements
mais marieelur finera h pour ce qui la
concerne nous communiquera beaucoup de
d'informations sur la réalit anise merci
beaucoup bonne fin de journée au
revoir